I remember when Inglorious Bastards was
sent to my house
and I read for it but I don't even
remember what I read for
and I was you know it was misspelled you
know yeah and thinking next turn I'll
never be in a Tarantino movie I'll never
cast me
one time he saw me at a bowling alley
goes [ __ ] Lex Luthor and I go [ __ ]
Quentin Tarantino yeah and we had a
moment that was it and I was like Hey
Google
and I was hoping that someday I'd be in
a Tarantino film yeah and you got to do
that you're one of the one of the few
yeah that got to be was it something he
sought at like he went after you I went
in and read like everyone else you did
read but I knew him not well at all we'd
met on a couple of occasions years prior
because I sought him out
so I had heard from Judd that uh before
the DVDs came out he had sent Tarantino
Freaks and Geeks on VHS
and uh I so he I knew he watched them
and according to Judd he liked them and
so this is now 2003 and Jimmy came alive
used to be live back in those days I
remember I don't know if I remember he
used to have guest hosts who would sit
with him for the week sure and uh
Quentin was one of them
and so I knew Jimmy I knew people at the
show and so that was a door that I had
opened to me anytime I wanted I could
just go you called and Jamie and asked
him uh I don't think I called Jimmy I
feel like I called Daniel
uh maybe Daniel or Ellison right Daniel
kellison or maybe Ken Crosby any of but
you got on I got I got there I went
backstage and you want a guest I was not
a guest you just wanted to go and hang
out oh just want to hang out in the
green room so that I could because I
knew it would be you to bring a poster
to get autograph no I was coming as a
attempting to come as a colleague right
right okay okay so you're there and so I
was there and I see Clinton I'm like hey
Quinn he's like hey what's up freaking
because I think Judd sent you the VHS he
goes oh oh yeah oh my God what a great
show that was Oh What a terrific show oh
yeah yeah let's talk let's talk and so
we went out and did the show and then
after the show ends we're all hanging in
Jimmy's dressing room
uh which was like the VIP area of the
green room and so I'm just sitting on
the couch in Jimmy's dressing room
talking to Quentin and we're talking
about Freaks and Geeks we're talking
about Kill Bill we're talking about
Regis Philbin for hours sure I as you do
uh like we're talking talking and now
time is going on and like people are
leaving and they're leaving and Jimmy's
gone and I didn't realize it's now just
the two of us sitting in this green room
we did not realize the main green room
area everyone's gone
and so it's been like 90 plus minutes
you're hanging out with Quentin
Tarantino for 90 minutes yes and so then
a security guy walks in and he's like I
hate to be a jerk but uh we kind of want
to go home
and you guys are the last two here so
and Chris like oh [ __ ] I had no idea I
was like yeah me neither sorry and
that's when we walked out and realized
no one was there
and so like we walk and his car is I
mean one step outside of the exit from
the building right uh you know there's
fans screaming from or whatever and like
we get outside and he goes oh man it was
really great talking with you I really
like to work together someday I'm like
yeah that'd be all right
let me think about I'll get back to you
I was like yeah that'd be great
uh that was it though and that was you
didn't bring up anything there was
nothing to bring up he was promoting
Kill Bill all right you know and so then
it was in the summer of 2008 that killed
Bill or excuse me uh bastards the script
was floating around town yes and
everyone went oh and it leaked and oh
you can read it and it's that and he's
looking for he's looking for actors he
needs to make these bastards and so I
called my people
and I was like I'd already read the
script you decide to get me in there if
you fail to get me an audition for this
I am not staying with this company like
not a chance
make this happen get me in that room and
they did and I went in and I read I met
with him and when he was just doing
generals
to start just general meetings did not
want people to read just wanted you to
come in say hello shoot the [ __ ] he
wanted to get a Vibe for who you were
which is Bonkers uh but I did and I had
to like bring a DVD with like one
serious scene one funny scene from my
you know real or whatever and so I had
that ready to go and I go in there and
God bless them I walk in and I was like
hey what's up Sam man good to see you
how you been it's been like four years
since I've seen him last right but like
nothing like no time had passed and we
immediately fell back into that uh
casual fun conversation that we'd had
years earlier
and we talked for like 20 or 30 minutes
and this is on a Friday and he's like
okay okay you know what I want you to
come back on Monday and and read read
for uh yudovic and I was like okay he's
like yeah just read read the script
hands me the script read the script and
just you know prepare yudovic
there's like many scenes so I went home
and memorized every udovic scene over
the weekend over the weekend and just
had it down down and so I went in on
Monday and we read Universe for 10
minutes and they said her and then he
was like no no donowitz
donowitz and then he has me read
donowitz
um to come back memorize and come back
no uh cold and uh so I looked at it for
a few minutes and then I went in and did
it and it's a donowitz scene that's not
in the movie by the way you probably
read for donovitz if I had to guess uh
and it's a scene that was shot but
someday God willing we'll all see it's
donowitz and an old Jewish lady played
by Cloris Leachman and it's him in
Boston before he ships off to war and
he's going that bat that he's got that's
got all the signatures on it those are
the names of the people from his Boston
Neighborhood are we still over in uh
Europe and had family in Boston he said
write write their names down here and
I'll go either find them or get
Vengeance for him
wow and so it's that scene it's [ __ ]
intense right